[music playing]
NARRATOR: Day breaks over
the lovely forested south rim
of the canyon lighting
up a dead pine that would
seem to have little purpose.
But this pine is the
central bank and trust
of the acorn woodpecker.
And every inch is
studded with neatly
arranged holes, the
woodpecker's safe deposit boxes.
Finding the absolutely perfect
little vault for every acorn
can be quite the puzzle.
Each hole has been drilled
to fit a certain nut shape.
[bird calls]
Keeping the treasure
house secure
requires a bonding of the
birds, a breeding collective
of several males
and females along
with their extended family who
make deposits and stand guard.
[bird calls]
[music playing]
They can be little
gymnasts when threats come
from above simply skittering
to the underside of the bank
branches.
This is just a false
alarm though, a raven,
the jokester of the canyon.
There are far more serious
threats from below.
Squirrels know exactly how the
woodpecker banks work and are
always casing the joint.
And who could blame him.
Just look at all those acorns.
This squirrel believes
in sharing the wealth.
But he better eat fast
and stuff those cheeks.
[bird calls]
The woodpecker bank
tellers hit the alarm.
And the security guards
swing into action.
[music playing]
The bank is secured
again, but it
won't be long before
the habitual thief
tries another stickup.